Guten Abend Herr Oberarzt, ich habe eine neue Patienten aufgenommen. Ich möchte über Sie kurz berichten. Haben Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Ja bitte.
Danke. Frau Stefanie Meyer ist 76 Jahre alt, 75 Kilogramm schwer und 1,70 Meter groß.
Frau Meyer ist eine 76-jährige Patientin, die sich heute bei uns wegen seit vier Monaten bestehender, langsam aufgetretener, zunehmender bilateraler Bein-Oedämie und Dyspne vorstellte.
Der Patientin zufolge sei die Dyspne beim Treppensteigen ab dem zweiten Stock aufgetreten und sie müsste eine Pause einlegen.
Sie berichtete über Orthopneu, deshalb müsse sie mit zwei Kissen halbsitzend schlafen.
Außerdem klagte sie über Nüktüri, Reizhusten und Tachikadi, die Fragen nach Angina Pectoris, kalte Schweiz, Engelgefühl in der Brust, Kopfschmerzen,
Erithem und Schmerzen an der Wade wurden verneint. Bei der vegetativen Anamnese seien die Folgenden bekannt.
Seit zwei Monaten, Diary, Nüktüri, zweimal in der Nacht, 4 Kilogramm Zunahme, die Zunahme von 4 Kilogramm innerhalb von zwei Monaten.
Die Formulierung ist einfacher.
Die Patientin sei vollständig gegen Kinderkrankheiten geimpft.
Die letzte Frauensachstätigkeit war vor zwei Jahren und alles war in Ordnung.
Sie ist seit 23 Jahren im Klimakterium.
Anfroerkrankungen gab sie Hypotriose seit 40 Jahren, Psoriasis vulgaris seit 45 Jahren,
Beidseitige Gonarthrose seit 10 Jahren und Katarakt, rechtseitiger Katarakt seit 5 Jahren an.
Die Patientin nehme L-Tyroxin 75 Mikrogramm morgens ein.
Sie benutze gegen Psoriasis vulgaris eine Cortisonsalbe bei Bedarf.
Sie nehme gegen Gonarthrose Ibuprofen 400 Milligramm bei Bedarf ein.
Bei der Patientin sei vor 20 Jahren eine Thyroidektomie durchgeführt worden.
Bei der Patientin mit 14. Lebensjahr eine Appendektomie durchgeführt worden.
Die Patientin habe Allergie gegen Pollen und diese Allergie äußert sich durch Rhinokonjunktivitis.
Sie sei keine Raucherin. Sie trinke zwei Gläser Rotwein am Wochenende.
Drogenkonsum wurde verneint. Sie treibe keinen Sport, keinen regelmäßig Sport.
In der Familienanamnese gab die Patientin an, dass der Vater während des Kriegs verstorben sei.
Die Mutter sei an Katsinom verstorben, als die Patientin 14 Jahre alt war.
Sie habe keine Geschwister und sie sei verwitwet, habe zwei gesunde Kinder.
Sie sei Rentnerin. Sie habe früher als Sekretärin gearbeitet. Sie habe keinen Stress im Alltag.
Ich gehe von einem Verdacht auf eine Herzinsuffizienz aus, da die Patientin typische Symptome dafür aufweist.
Die Patientin leidet unter belastungsabhängiger Dyspne, Blätterabeinödeme, Tachikardie, Orthopne und paroxysmale nocturnal Dyspne.
Als Differenzia-Diagnosen kommen Niereninsuffizienz, Lungenembolie, Lebeninsuffizienz, Herzkrankheit.
Zunächst würde ich bei der Patientin eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf ab...
Zunächst würde ich bei der Patientin die Vitalparameter überwachen und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung achte ich darauf an, ob Hautfarbeveränderungen, Öffnungen und Vorwanderungen vorhanden sind.
Ich kontrolliere peripherale arteriale Pulse, ich teste den Bauch ab, ich höre Lungen ab.
Wenn du sie auch nennen willst, kannst du sie auch nennen.
Bei der Palpation würde ich den Bauch abtasten, ob die Patientin Druckschmerzen oder Abwehrschmerzen hat.
Ich würde die peripherale Pulse abtasten, um eine PVK auszuschließen.
Zusätzlich sind eine Laboruntersuchung sinnvoll, um eine umfassende Diagnostik zu gewährleisten.
Ich würde die Lokosystemzahl CAP, BSG, der Dumere, BNP, Leberwerte, Nierenwerte, Elektrolyte und Gerührungsparameter bestimmen lassen.
Außerdem würde ich eine Echokardiographie und LKG durchführen, um die Herzrhythmusstörungen und Herzwandstörungen und Klappensstörungen auszuschließen.
Ich würde die Karteo-Liches-Konzil anfordern, um die Therapie der Patienten zu optimieren.
Außerdem würde ich die Patienten ein paar Tage stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde die Patienten ein paar Tage stationär aufnehmen.
Ich würde den Patienten Lebensstilveränderungen und regelmäßige Sport machen.
Wenn Sie mit dieser Vorgehensweise einverstanden sind, werde ich mit der geplanten Untersuchung fortfahren.
Ich würde die Patienten ein paar Tage stationär aufnehmen.
Der Patient ist zur Person, zur Seite und Ort orientiert.